la ligue communiste où la seconde
jeunesse du trotskisme un trotskiste que
l'on croyait surtout voué aux querelles
d'écoles ou relégué au musée de la
révolution la ligue communiste est issue
après une scission des jeunesses
communistes des jcm ou jeunesse
communiste révolutionnaire déjà dissoute
en juin 68
un théoricien le belge n ernest mandel
que l'on vit clamé sur les premières
barricades de 68 à comme c'est beau la
révolution
et surtout un leader alain krivine
orateur connu du grand public depuis sa
candidature à la présidence de la
république
à la ligue l'organisation décide de tout
en commençant bien sûr par celle du
service dont un service d'ordre dans la
dernière intervention revanche la
semaine dernière a surpris la plupart
des observateurs
par sa force de choc sa mobilité son
adaptation à la stratégie des combats de
rue
entre nouveau la référence par est
explicite pourtant ses dirigeants se
défendent de vouloir seulement versé du
vin nouveau dans les vieilles outres du
facisme mais ce mouvement qui tient son
premier congrès en soixante dix ne
dissimule pas ses liens avec les mii
signer aux fassis italien giorgio
almirante
piètre ocz rôles le député msi de
bologne assistait d'ailleurs au congrès
d'ordre nouveau dont une délégation
participera ensuite au séminaire de
monter silvan organisée par les jeunes
néo fascistes italiens
aux dernières élections ordre nouveau le
fup une composante du front national de
jean marie le pen qui se voulait un
rassembleur de la droite nationale sans
pouvoir dépasser cependant 2,3 pour cent
des voix
l'ambition d'ordre nouveau occuper le
terrain sur le plan de la lutte
quotidienne contre le gauchisme selon
l'exemple donné à la faculté d'assas par
le guide tout en s'opposant en même
temps au régime au système